En el video anterior hablamos sobre Francisco
Vieta y sus fórmulas aplicadas a ecuaciones de
segundo grado. En este video quiero que pensemos
en polinomios de tercer grado. ¿Cómo se verá la
expresión de las fórmulas de Vieta en ecuaciones
de tercer grado? Es decir, supongamos que tenemos
el polinomio p(x) = x³ + bx² + cx + d y que
r₁, r₂ y r₃ son las raíces del polinomio,
es decir p(r₁) = p(r₂) = p(r₃) = 0. Entonces,
sabemos que podemos escribir a p(x) como, bueno,
(x - r₁) (x - r₂) (x - r₃), y si hacemos el
producto notable, tenemos que, bueno: (x - r₁)
(x - r₂) = (x² - (r₁ + r₂) x + r₁ • r₂), y a esto
hay que multiplicarlo por (x - r₃), entonces me
queda: x² • x³ es lo mismo que x³ + -r₁ + r₂
todo esto por x por x, es lo mismo que menos,
que multiplica a (r₁ + r₂) x² + r₁ r₂ x, bueno eso
es r₁ r₂ x + x² por -r₃, eso es -r₃ x² más menos
que multiplican a r₁ r₂ x, y esto por -r₃, bueno,
eso es lo mismo que r₁ r₃ + r₂ r₃ y todo esto x,
y por último tenemos r₁ r₂ -r₃, que es lo mismo
que -r₁ r₂ r₃. Ahora bien, podemos factorizar
un poco. Primero tenemos x³, después tenemos
menos que multiplican a (r₁ + r₂) x² - r₃x²,
bueno eso es lo mismo que menos que multiplica
a (r₁ + r₂ + r₃) todo esto por x². Perfecto,
hemos acabado con los términos cuadráticos, ahora
pensemos en los términos que tienen x elevada
a la primera potencia: r₁ r₂ x + r₁ r₃ + r₂ r₃
todo esto por x, bueno, esto es lo mismo que (r₁
r₂ + r₁ r₃ + r₂ r₃) todo esto por x; perfecto.
Y, por último, sólo tenemos al -r₁ r₂ r₃,
a éste como término constante. Ahora, usando
la misma idea de Vieta, si x³ + bx² + x + d
tiene que ser igual a todo esto que tenemos aquí,
entonces se debe cumplir que -r₁ r₂ r₃, esto debe
de ser igual a b, aunque r₁ + r₂ + r₃ debe de
ser igual a -b, y que (r₁ r₂ + r₁ r₃ + r₃ r₂)
esto debe de ser igual a c, y r₁ r₂ r₃ debe de
ser igual a -d. Y estas son las tres fórmulas de
Vieta para una ecuación de tercer grado, así
que hagamos un ejemplo para tener mucho más
claro todo esto. Esta vez nos dicen: encuentra las
soluciones de la ecuación x³ - 3x² - 6x + 8 = 0,
es decir nos piden las raíces del polinomio x³
- 3x² - 6x + 8, y antes de pedirte que pauses
el video y que intentes encontrar las soluciones
de esta ecuación, te voy a dar una pista: siempre
es más fácil resolver ecuaciones sin términos de
segundo grado, y es que en todos los polinomios
de tercer grado podemos eliminar el término de
segundo grado haciendo un cambio de variable. Si
pensamos en x como una nueva variable, t - b/3,
podemos conseguir eliminar el término cuadrático
de nuestra expresión, es decir, si x es igual a
t - b/3, que, en este caso b = -3, entonces nos
queda que x = t -(-3)/ 3, lo cual nos da que x = t
+ 1, ¿cómo nos quedaría nuestro polinomio? Bueno,
nos quedará (t + 1)³ - 3 que multiplica a (t + 1)²
- 6 que multiplica a (t + 1) + 8, ya que en lugar
de x pondremos t + 1. Entonces, al desarrollar
tenemos que t + 1, esto al cubo, es lo mismo que
t³ + 3t² + 3t + 1 y -3 que multiplica a (t + 1)²
es lo mismo que -3 que multiplica a (t² + 2t + 1),
que es lo mismo que -3t² - 6t - 3, y por último
-6 que multiplica a (t + 1) y esto más 8,
es lo mismo que -6t - 6 + 8, y eso es lo mismo
que t³, 3t² - 3t², se cancelan, 3t - 6t - 6t,
esto es lo mismo que -9t y 1 - 3 - 6 + 8, esto
me da 0. Entonces todo se simplificó en t³ - 9t,
y es momento de que pausa es el video y que
pienses las soluciones de la ecuación t³ - 9t = 0,
y recuerdes que buscamos las soluciones para la
ecuación original, así que también resuelve para x
una vez que obtengas las soluciones para t. Bien,
vamos a trabajar juntos. Encontrar las soluciones
de t³ - 9t = 0 es muy fácil si factorizamos el
lado izquierdo, pero vamos a usar las fórmulas
de Vieta para resolverlo, porque es nuestro tema
en este video. Las fórmulas de Vieta nos dicen
que r₁ + r₂ + r₃ = -b, pero en este caso b, que
es el coeficiente del término de segundo grado,
es cero, ya que no tenemos términos de segundo
grado; entonces r₁ + r₂ + r₃ = 0. Por otra parte
tenemos que, r₁ r₂ + r₁ r₃ + r₃ r₂ es igual a c,
es decir, el coeficiente del término de grado 1,
que en este caso es -9, entonces debe de ser igual
a -9, y por último tenemos que el producto de las
raíces es r₁ r₂ r₃, y esto debe de ser igual a
-d, que es el coeficiente constante, pero tampoco
tenemos término constante, entonces r₁ r₂ r₃ =
0. Y aquí está la clave: buscamos el producto de
tres números igual a cero, lo que quiere decir
que al menos uno debe de ser cero, así que,
supongamos que r₁ = 0. ¿Cómo nos quedarían las
otras dos expresiones de Vieta? Bueno, la primera
nos quedaría que r₁ + r₂ + r₃ = 0, pero como r₁ es
0, entonces me queda que r₂ + r₃ = 0, muy bien, y
la segunda si r₁ = 0, entonces r₁ r₂, bueno, esto
es 0 + r₁ r₃, esto también es 0, es decir, sólo
nos queda que r₃ r₂ = -9. Dicho de otra manera,
hemos reducido el problema a encontrar dos números
cuya suma sea 0 y cuyo producto sea -9, claro son
13 - 3, entonces: r₁ = 0, r₂ = 3 y r₃ = -3. Ahora,
ten cuidado; ya hemos encontrado las raíces para
la ecuación t³ - 9t = 0, sin embargo, no hemos
terminado el problema, porque nosotros queríamos
las soluciones o raíces para la ecuación original,
la ecuación cuya variable es x, es decir x³ -
3x² - 6x + 8 = 0. ¿Cómo las encontramos? Bueno,
recordemos el cambio de variable. Usamos como
cambio de variable x = t + 1, así podemos
encontrar los tres valores de x que son las raíces
o soluciones al problema original. Entonces,
x₁ = 0 + 1, lo cual es 1, x₂ = 3 + 1, lo cual es
4, y x₃ = -3 + 1, lo cual es -2. Estas tres son
las raíces o soluciones de la ecuación original.
Así que nos vemos en el siguiente video. Saludos.